hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to SCP containment
breach unity edition now there's been
some updates to the game it's still
early in this version of the games
development there are some new creatures
there are some new monsters and there
are some new rooms to see there's new
threats to explore like the last one it
had a lot of really cool things in it
but this one in particular is the
release that's coming just before the
point-six release of the game which
should provide a lot more stuff now the
opening shouldn't be too much different
than what we saw before so it'll take a
little bit to get into and you guys
don't worry I will skip ahead if there's
anything that needs to be
[Music]
okay I'm not sure what I've seen and
what I haven't seen so I'm gonna just
you know go through everything exist as
if I haven't hello hmm where's the poopy
man I didn't see no poopy man hey them's
good eats who left this behind
no what have we got here attention
personnel a site lockdown is in fact tip
for the day don't panic it won't help
nothing at all will help but panicking
will probably help the least okay that's
good Alice's move on
all right the poop mice what way whoa
hey whoa hey whoa hey why don't I have a
blink meter wait a minute am I even
playing the right game here whoa
poopy man whoa that's a problem oh
that's cool animations on you
okay wait listen wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait
oh god lag Paul okay or a hang on here I
don't have I don't have any interface I
don't know when I'm not blinking so
maybe it's like hang on let me just back
up let me back up a second because
something something good about that oh
god here we go
lor friendly mode I don't know what that
means but I didn't have any interface so
I'm supposing that maybe this is gonna
be different
bubble bath bomb bonds what a bubble
bath bonbons okay well I guess I'm just
not gonna have a blink meter at all cuz
that seems like something that I
definitely shouldn't have a blink o
meter I guess I just gotta log it in my
head maybe when I blink in real life
that's when it blinks in-game maybe
that's what I gotta go about it yeah any
sense yeah makes sense
starvin balloon I've got this save save
is f5 okay so we're good let's just keep
moving here Superman is not there that's
okay
we don't need booby man there hello what
did i do what did I do
what did I do did I do
we'll say lockdown okay
Hey
good
oh that's new okay so I was supposed to
do that that's not a bad thing that was
good
never mind I guess I'll go the other way
then I don't need to be go that way hey
goodbye oh hey I'll miss me [ __ ] okay
ah what what what's the wait huh well
hey man but wait a minute
wait I can see it's alright what the
[ __ ] is that about what is that what is
that oh boy what what no what what wait
wait a minute
wait what I thought am I crazy or was
there someone
I'm up am I crazy
am I crazy about that my crazy Beth I
might be crazy about that I'm entirely
crazy about that huh okay let's forget
about that thought I saw like a body
standing next to me okay that's what's
with the weird void rooms I think this
is a loading error Oh
what is happening what is happening what
is that [ __ ] what is that that's not
supposed to happen
this game is messed up this game's
messed up game's messed up that's really
cool I don't know where we are
well we're in a cold area better for
containment I suppose
a flamingo how you doing how you doing
Mingo this is new where am I what no
right now you kidding me what did you do
now I got a blow I got a Mingo okay I
guess I'm fine then he's too busy
dealing with somebody else I don't know
what he's dealing with but he's not
dealing with me which is a good thing
hey buddy how you doing oh okay that's
weird
so yeah I'm assuming he's stuck
you can't go this way definitely can't
go that oh okay
is this a game of red light green light
hey Larry Larry Larry
hi how you what are you doing I don't
like that twitchy leg how you doing
there buddy
ah you seem like you've had better days
oh he's he's just defending the goal
okay all right then well you really
smudged up the Mingo over there but I'm
gonna try to slip pass maybe some of the
loading errors will fix themselves but
nope nope okay I'm just going for it
here we go wherever we are in the void -
whatever it does oh okay Oh Lego Lego
lag oh this games broken duh I think
this games blah things games broken this
game might be just a little bit borked
okay what is this area this is a bunch
of nothing there's a whole lot of
nothingness there's a whole lot of
nothingness
I don't know what I'm grabbing grabbing
some things ho ho ho
whoa hey how you doing okay oh okay it
says you're safe I don't trust that
autonomous non-standard space-time oh
okay all right then don't know what
that's all about what's in here I saw an
armed grabby okay all right
well I like you but I think it's okay
what did I grab I got the ring is that
the ring nope okay that crashed the game
oh yeah that crashed the game god damn
it work in progress everybody okay I'm
back I had to revert down to another
version of this game but this game is
such a big file that it took forever to
download so I don't know if there are
any less creatures in this version it's
only a point zero point zero point one
decrease and it's still a much higher
version than the last time that I played
what I am
well that that wasn't even in the other
one that's so cool this is so much
better
what even the music's working better
what the hell is happening they didn't
have any of this in the last one even
the Lighting's better everything is
better about this one well that's so
weird one blinking 'he's working right
away seems darker and dreary er so I
already got that one okay so this is
much better hopefully it doesn't crash
or anything this game is like this
version of it has a lot of ambition put
into it and I can definitely understand
that they're trying to amp it up in a
big way and I can see how these
incremental updates can break things as
things go along but this is hopefully
going to be much better alright so let's
get into this I don't know what I did
before that I didn't do this oh it's
different I forgot it's still all
randomly generated okay but that's gonna
kick on the ventilation system and then
we're gonna be back to where we were
going for and then we can explore this
place to a good degree and then we can
get the pants scared off of us in the
correct way possible and not in the dumb
way so let's do this
[Music]
okay yeah why do you sound like the
plague doctor oh my god let's go oh yeah
Ronen smoother too oh there we go
I'm pretty sure that's what that was
supposed to be and not what it was
before okay okay oh hi oh hey you uh
your demon oh you're definitely oh
you're horrible you're like a ghost duck
what are you Kodak's
there we go some codexes wait wait wait
whoa hey whoa hey whoa hey whoa hey whoa
hey whoa you are a ghost duck okay all
right then that's des cute Oh duck
appears to be a duck holding a small
saxophone which is observed to play at
random intervals of all emitting a
single drawn-out note followed by a
series of melodically unrelated notes
significantly shriller than those
produced by a traditional saxophone
thomas is appearing to a duck wearing a
sheet similar to a simplistic Halloween
ghost costume Chuck has been observed
float five to seven centimeters above
the solid and liquid surfaces to weigh
down face through the duct objects
influences the perceptions of any object
holding it and any person speaking to it
the affected subject object in fact
appears to be a flamingo
ah so that's what that flamingo duck was
all about oh okay all right
hello hello okay
all right cool all these are about the
same oh we're done are you done duck
goose duck fine whatever I'm out of here
I didn't need you anyway I need anybody
just me myself and I and probably Billy
and Larry also Larry can't forget about
Larry okay well I got that oh it's the
candy uh oh I like the candy all right
take no more than two please one puh got
it thank you for that I don't want to go
get another one I've already died to
that only me to die again I'm just gonna
eat my candy and that'll be that
can I eat it use no apparently not the
glass is good this is what I needed all
right get it all dark applier up in here
hey whoa hey whoa well I guess that's
normal
Oh Oh Billy
what are you doing in the corner what
are you doing Billy you stuck what are
you stuck oh god oh god oh god oh god
God well this has been unpleasant this
way before Billy didn't go this way all
right here we go ah the machine well
well well well well well well indeed I
don't think I have anything that can
actually put in here that'll be getting
good but the candy I guess drop all
right so we got some candy in there
let's make it fine baby oh well that's
cool
well that's awful ooh okay what did it
do to it it's a chocolate bar now that
it's a hurry's chocolate bar num num
that was delicious
sure I'm glad I hate that it's probably
not gonna be any bad for me okay well I
did that I don't know what uh faster
wait is that why it's called hurries oh
my faster I might be faster I might I
might be faster wait a minute oh wait
have I been here
yeah I've already been here okay well
that's new
I guess well tell you about that which
are going this way no I'm gonna start
leaving doors open so I know where I've
been
okay wait a minute
what wait what no oh god it's amazing I
have been here before god dammit okay
alright then all these leads back to the
same circles why why where Wow no no Oh
wah wah wah wah wah wah
whee whoa no whoa no whoa no big whoa no
on you I know he's gonna rape you walk
oh god I've been that way skadoosh okay
god damn how do I keep doing this how do
I keep doing this okay I'm on spring
break but I drank by you cuz I got
hurries baby when you flew I've got a
belly full of hurries oh [ __ ] there we
go when you got a belly full of hurries
you've got places to be
okay no God why there's no way to go
there's no this is no way to go oh it's
coming back up this is no way to go
where do I go this goes back to home
there's no way to go I've been
everywhere here dare everywhere had been
everywhere he down here oh he's back
he keeps uh-uh okay I guess not I guess
I have not no [ __ ] me are you done you
done Larry done you persistent douchebag
okay that's me okay he's not he's not
done he's not done he's not done Hank
how's it going there buddy okay hang on
we got to find a way yeah I know I know
I know very funny extremely funny oh god
oh god oh god I don't have time to grab
what it was everything in there you're
gonna find like a Tesla gate that's the
only thing that's gonna be able to stop
him but of course I'm not gonna get any
Tesla gates they're not gonna do that
for me I don't know holy [ __ ] Jesus oh
good plants that's good I guess what
does that mean what is that why do I
hear all the doors why do I hear other
doors no where's this go
ah [ __ ] ah [ __ ] I'm going down up down
up down down up down up no listen you
don't want to do this listen you just
patiently waiting for the elevator to
get to wherever we're going and I'm
going now I don't know where I'm going I
don't know where I'm going I don't know
where I'm going I don't know what that
is
what is [ __ ] oh [ __ ] what is that a
holographic duck watch it wash it wash
it wash it huh ah [ __ ]
ah [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
[Music]
I'm [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] I am [ __ ]
I am [ __ ] I have been [ __ ] oh God
why won't you let go Larry Larry why
will you not let go
Nosa me between me it put me it's with
me oh god oh god oh god oh god I'm
running yeah
yo'ii oh god why God why go go go okay
we're fine Oh why can you be done can
you just be done can you
[Music]
I'm stuck in this elevator aren't I
yep I'm stuck ok well alright ok ha okay
let's try that again if it'll actually
load which I don't know if it will it
might not but then that's okay nope
looks like it's not going to okay
alright well that that was an experience
okay
alright we gotta start over again great
oh this is new Oh
do not enter test chamber without
protective equipment you can't tell me
out oh oh I guess I can't go there
anyway well you can't tell me how to
live my life
oh no oh not this guy
oh not Senor jump scares a lot oh not
you
alright well you're fine you're fine
oh god it's gonna be a brownie record
[Music]
where is it Rosie
oh I know he's here ah I know he's here
okay whatever it's fine so he's not
gonna bug me
maybe containment passage what is
everything was that Sam what am I
looking at
I know what I'm looking at oh the
[ __ ] god damn you you piece of [ __ ]
okay some kind of camera I don't I don't
know what that's about
why okay whatever that's new oh here we
go the level up so maybe there's gonna
be something at the tippy-top of this
one that I actually need but it's gonna
be the same thing as before I guess but
maybe there was something in that room
that I actually needed I don't know oh
it's so pretty
oh it's so pretty it's real pretty guys
it's real pretty Hey look they're both
up there now well how am I gonna be able
to get you if you're both up there of
course I forgot
these are all lockers ah okay but
there's nothing in them that I need
right they were empty okay
I guess were fine then all right good
okay great all right oh there was
nothing there I don't think anyway
that's not okay five five five way back
I didn't know I didn't see there was
nothing
where's the screen how do I uh uh how do
I put it
what are we blank okay all right I guess
not
okay everything's fine everything's fine
come on eat I'm just on edge a bit and I
don't know why I don't need to be so
stressed oh good another one of these
this is what I was hoping for another
one of these situations these are my
favorite okay the room here I don't know
if I need any of these papers a lot of
big papers this time just papers out the
wazoo
alright papers out the wazoo that's
great okay I didn't need those for any
reason but I have them why
okay okay okay Oh what is this what is
this why is it red No
it's a decontamination thing it's fine
who's cool let's chill it's tight fine
whatever ain't got no problems with that
oh this was the one that goes down it's
the butterfly cavern right get butterfly
cavern butterflies are fine butterflies
are beautiful butterflies are delightful
little things that fly and our made of
butter they're delicious
okay contain my ass
no one can contain my ass my ass is
practically uncontainable okay so I'm
just gonna be in here and out real quick
I don't know if they have anything
that's necessary down here I'm gonna out
now okay nothing knows not the not a
good idea not the goodest idea the hi
are you blocking my way
are you I can't run are you blocking my
way right now you better not be blocking
my way you get out of the way you get
out of the way
you sack of [ __ ] I thought you would
have been gone by now
piece of crap can I get some first aid
damn it I need a hurry bar got him so
tense and it's fine
that's an endless series of corridors
okay there's the machine but I don't
need the machine because I don't have
anything yet
I haven't unlocked anything either that
was in the other game so I haven't
unlocked a lockdown somewhere in the
sub-basement level I am to think I could
do that because I don't think I'd get
back up but maybe that was just because
radical Larry was there and I was
technically pressing as many buttons as
it possible could that guy's dead what
the [ __ ] was that [ __ ] the [ __ ] was that
[ __ ] what was that what's the music all
about what is this gas masks okay but
[ __ ] why oh and you're going oh okay
alright that makes a lot of sense sack
of [ __ ] you piece of [ __ ] tiny box Tim
are you here what did I just get what
did I just get what did I get
gumdrops say before I eat those okay
oh no what happened
why no hey wait I'm I'm leaking I'm
leaking
I'm considerably leaking I'm leaking
concern why did I leak
that's a Skoosh Oh God did that's a
Skoosh me full of light it's like a
bubble bath thing oh yeah yeah okay
whatever I'm gonna go ahead and die cuz
I got nothing better to do with my time
okay but that's fine I'm not worried
about that
yeah miss dr. wonder Taemin's bubble
bath bonbons oh we made a bubble bath
out of me turn me into a bubble bath
okay though that's fine guess whatever
though I don't think there was anything
else of value in here anyway just bubble
bath blonde blondes and a bunch of tiny
box types oh there he is
okay whatever I'm out of here it's not
even important
oh I also got something else I need to
get out here go go go go go go go go go
go go go I think I got something else
anyway no hum % sure but I think I got
something else ok come on my run Oh
meters keeps running out on me ok there
you are oh well this is lovely well this
looks lovely I don't think I'm gonna be
able to hang around a little bit but
looks lovely I'll go up this staircase
whoa
very nice ok what have you got here I've
been getting so many of these codexes
but I haven't been able to read any of
them whoa it's not a helmet or a bell is
that a below oh ok all right cool don't
know what that's about but ok oh nice
very nice very nice all of this just
lovely very homey doesn't seem to be
anything that's necessary around here
maybe these are just for decorations ok
what do we have here
recovery log other log informational
blurbs
stuff that I don't need it looks like
Larry's gone which is a first I didn't
think he was actually gonna go away at
this point that's locked down I don't
know if there's a way to unlock it but
that doesn't seem like it something goes
behind that painting maybe no it's all
locked down maybe these are just for
flavor here I don't know but I don't
need to be here there's another way
through okay more always okay ah this is
official-looking okay I think they'd
actually do something with this place
and not just having to be a long series
of hallways seems like there might be I
need to be some urgency what the [ __ ]
did I just see that's not a good sound
but I'm gonna ignore it
well this looks bad Oh bathrooms butt
ghost butt ghost butt butt ghost butt
ghost butt ghost no thought ghosts you
hear butt ghost butt ghost
but ghosts you're the buck coast is the
buck ghost here buck go stay here that's
fine I haven't seen that's right I
haven't seen the bathrooms in the
original SCP canaima breached in ages
the butt ghost was like a thing and then
the putco suddenly wasn't a thing maybe
he's just cuz I couldn't find the
bathrooms again probably I never did
make it far again in the game but I will
I will go back to that bad version of
the game the real version of the game
the heart right everybody
oh there's that good think that's fair
well that doesn't do anything that just
circles around why would I go there I
don't even need to go there why would I
go there if I didn't need to go there
I've got every avenue that circumvents
in that direction oh no it all just goes
back it all leads to the same place okay
well you know I don't really need to do
it it's all open so I don't know where I
am it's been a while
probably oh it has
oh we've most certainly has ok whatever
I've got this and I'm gonna get some
candy if you love some candy and a
rubber duckie
what else did I get the gas mask that's
right oh yeah this place forgot about
this oh they're praying I guess why you
go pray digging it up take it enough I
take it off I took it off I took it ah
where am I whoa well
looks like it worked man I mean it's
really cool what they got going on here
but it's very obvious that they've got a
lot of kinks to work out they've got
some really cool stuff going on here but
it's breaking a bit and it's like nah I
wish it was she was a little bit better
but unfortunately it's still got some
problems I mean the original him I can't
fault it because the original game like
SCP containment breach the very original
one it had a lot of problems throughout
its development and they need a lot of
help from the community to be able to
make it into something a bit better that
doesn't mean that it's in any way bad
but it had a lot of time to develop
itself and this one just hasn't had as
much time to develop itself
okay now we're here so let me turn this
on because maybe getting the ventilation
system going is actually something that
you need to do later on in the game I
know I don't know I'm gonna explore what
I can I don't think that there's any
conclusion to be reached right now I
definitely know that there's no
conclusion to be reached right now so
it's kind of just a free-form
exploration kind of thing what that
being said
okay it's online let's just go for it
okay that just leads back and forth I
think this is curved around no there's a
right here so we'll just go where does
this go oh this way I came
oh well alright I don't remember leaving
the doors open like I didn't leave and
that one just opened for me I don't know
I don't know and it's not too terribly
important right now but that is
something that concerns me greatly I'm
just gonna
I'm just gonna assume assume that it's
until proven otherwise it's fine
okay we're going back the way we came
I think there's got to be an offshoot
somewhere then I need to take cuz I got
the ventilation system but that's just a
loop it's yes I see okay we're gonna go
down we're gonna try to release the
lockdown whatever that's gonna do
but hopefully
hopefully wait this is a different part
of the basement
this is a different area there are two
elevators there were two places that I
could have gone you're an Argo you're a
now go
you're a now go I'm following ya
creeping up on your boy go ahead go
ahead go ahead
oh no it's just a different part of it
oh I see okay there's that weird
holographic duck again duck applier dark
a duck
weird I can't pick this one up it's like
a disco duck or something like that okay
someone released lockdown hopefully
there he ain't gonna come by I'm gonna
try to go up the same elevator that I
came down to because the first one I did
it seemed to be kind of broken
lockdown overridden lockdown disengaged
I think he's gonna resume his patrol oh
no he's going the other way now okay all
right that's fine
there isn't up there but I don't know
how to get up there that's still locked
down so it's not like that opened up but
this is open what is this ah this is how
you get up there okay good so now I'm up
here I should be away from the mister
dude down there and I should be fine
right that's not a good sound that's
that's not good these aren't good sounds
these are not good sounds ha ha
and
oh I think he's mad at me I think he
wants to find me but I don't think he's
gonna be able to okay we're gonna get
out of here I think this is a convenient
way to get away from him but it's not
going so conveniently because he seems
to be locked on pretty tightly I don't
know if I'm gonna be able to Skoosh my
way out of here
oh yeah he is he is locked on me
oh he is so on my business no no no no
no no no whoa no wait no wait no wait no
way no way no way what the hell
well this sucks he's now perma stuck to
me okay there's a way that I I think I
can do this if I lure him up here all
the way up and then shut a door in his
face
come get up here yeah yeah yeah oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] he's not behind me Damon
okay okay I got an idea
lure him up here I'll try to outrun him
once he gets up here yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay I try to go the other way
I ran out of run that's not good
oh there's no way how the [ __ ] I can
take it and it'll go up and it'll
actually close or open
oh-ho-oh of course Scott D of course
that's what I get for celebrating a
little bit that's not good I don't think
my saves are working either oh this is
nice
I've already been in an area like this
before haven't I there was nothing up
there okay boy he's still here
all right no Tesla gate Scott Damon my
first run through this I find a bunch of
Tesla games now nothing no Tesla gates
for anybody especially not me Oh
No I've already been here I've already
been here is this the same area don't I
already have the Bubblegum
have I been here did I just somehow loop
back to the area that I bet I have
haven't I oh no no that's bad oh that's
bad that's bad okay I have no idea where
I am
[ __ ] [ __ ] maybe I can get Larry in one
of this come on Larry get in here I'm
gonna grind you up into dust whirring
get in that machine there's no way that
I could is there
now's hoping it was gonna like slam the
door and slam him in there but no you
are just a son-of-a-bitch ancient yeah
you are you are that's what you get I
mean you didn't get anything so whatever
I've been here before I'm just going to
ask backwards at this point oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] well I'm not gonna go oh no oh he's
so hurt I'm gonna go back I'm not gonna
go that way because I've been there
before so I don't think that there's any
value with going back I gotta at least
try to keep moving forward
Oh bad bad bad bad bad bad bad bad bad
bad bad bad
rad rad bad rad and bad rad man shake
bake baby
[Music]
hey you
whoo I know I've been here know been
here I've been here been her I bent her
been here been hurt
Oh Rick duh [ __ ] you know what I think
I'm doomed I'm just gonna try my luck
with the monsters whoa I'm gonna try my
luck with the monsters in the basement
if they can at least show me a good time
I'll be relatively happy okay I don't
know what else to do so I think this is
gonna be the end of this and in order to
finish it off in glorious fashion oh
yeah buddy oh wow you're a big boy oh
you're a big boy oh you're a big boy now
well anyway that is SCP containment
breach unity remake the update for now I
will play this again when the point-six
release is out which hopefully won't be
too much longer and hopefully they fix a
lot of the bugs because I like that they
keep adding new features but also it's
like whenever they add new features they
break something else so thank you so
much for watching and as always I'll see
you
bye-bye
[Music]